망원경부터 대형 강입자 충돌기까지
새로운 과학적 도구들은 우리가 과학자로서
그리고 호기심 많은 사람으로서
합리적으로 물어볼 수 있는 질문들을 새롭게 만들어왔어요
고성능 컴퓨팅, 즉 HPC는
60년대에 그 엘리트 목록에 합류했어요. 오늘날
quantum 컴퓨터들이 같은 문을 두드리고 있습니다.
안녕하세요, 저는 IBM Quantum의
소프트웨어 엔지니어예요
이 과정에서 저희는 학생들과
전문가들에게 quantum computing이 곧
HPC 인프라와 함께
어떻게 연산을 제공하게 될지 가르치려고 해요
quantum과
고전 컴퓨터가 어떻게 통신하고 데이터를 교환하는지,
두 가지 유형의 하드웨어를 활용하는 프로그램 작성법,
그리고 이 통합이 오늘날 해결할 수 있는 애플리케이션들을 어떻게 여는지 배울 거예요
실제 quantum 하드웨어와
고전적인 고성능 컴퓨팅 클러스터를 통해
전통적인 HPC 워크로드와 함께 quantum 작업을 실행하는
실용적인 경험을 쌓고 결과를 자신 있게 해석하며
quantum 가속이 계산에 실질적으로
도움이 될 수 있는 곳과
그렇지 않은 곳을 파악하게 될 거예요. 무엇보다도 컴퓨터의 미래가
어디로 향하고 있는지,
그리고 거기에 도달하기 위한 로드맵을 이해하게 될 거예요. 저희는
이 과정이 중요하고
시의적절하다고 생각하며,
이 기술들을 결합하는 게 계산적 우위를
달성하는 데 필수적일 거라고 믿어요
이건 화학 같은 다양한 산업에 광범위한 영향을 미칠 수 있어요
더 빠른 신약 설계와 소재 연구를
가능하게 하거나,
금융에서는
더 스마트한 위험 모델과
사기 탐지, 인공지능과 머신러닝에서는
모델 최적화에 활용될 수 있어요. 이 과정에서
컴퓨터 자원에 대해 깊이 파고들고
프로그래밍 모델과 quantum 알고리즘을 다룰 거예요
환영합니다, 함께 즐겁게 해봐요
이야기할 게 정말 많아요